this is jaco podcast number 156 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening I come good evening resistance
why didn't you resist today those who
have continued to live on and comfort
scold those who suffered yes resistance
should have begun right there at the
moment of the arrest itself but it did
not begin during a daylight arrest there
is always that brief and unique moment
when they are leading you either
inconspicuously on the basis of a
cowardly deal you have made or else
quite openly their pistols on holstered
through a crowd of hundreds of just such
doomed innocence as yourself you aren't
gagged you really can and you really
ought to cry out to cry out you are
being arrested that villains in disguise
are trapping people that arrests are
being made on the strength of false
denunciations that millions are being
subjected to silent reprisals if many
such out cries had been heard all over
the city in the course of a day would
not our fellow citizens perhaps have
begun to bristle and what a rat and what
arrests perhaps no longer have been so
easy instead not one sound comes from
your parched lips and that passing crowd
naively believes that you and your
executioner's are friends out for a
stroll
I myself often had the chance to cry out
so why did I keep silent
why in my last minute out in the open
did I not attempt to enlighten the
hoodwinked crowd why did I keep silent
every man always has a dozen glib little
reasons why he is right not to sacrifice
himself some still have hopes of a
favorable outcome to their case and are
afraid to ruin their chances by outcry
so they keep silent and that right there
is part of the opening of book 1 part 1
of the book The Gulag Archipelago by
source Nitin and I discussed it on the
last podcast with Jordan Peterson but I
didn't dig into the actual text very
much because well I had Jordan Peterson
on here and I would rather just talk
with him and allow him to talk rather
than read and delve into the text itself
but the text is really good and I wanted
to take today to go through at least
well to go through today part 1 of The
Gulag Archipelago and the version that
I'm going through is not the abridged
version but the full unabridged version
so if you end up looking for some of
these passages in the abridged version
you might not find them and I'm only
going to go through part one today and
maybe over time we'll go through all
seven parts that are in three different
volumes massive volumes by the way this
one is 600 pages long part two volume
two it looks like about another 600
pages and then volume three looks to be
I don't know maybe four or five hundred
pages so I think we're talking maybe
1,500 to 2,000 pages but it's a it's a
great read and like I said in the future
if you get these will go will I will
say this in the future yes we will go
through all the books if you want to get
them now and read them then eventually
you'll be able to roll through them with
us and it's as I said I mean this this
this book is a very powerful book but I
said this one when I was talking to
Jordan it's written and you could hear
from even the opening there it's it's
almost a conversation it's a very
conversational writing that social
Knutson does and so it's it's pretty
easy to read because it's not it's just
very calm it sounds like somebody's
telling you a story is basically what
it's like he's got asking you questions
rhetorical questions he's interacting
with you the reader so it's a pretty fun
read and it's not fun in the fact that
you're reading about people being
trapped tortured murdered in a gulag but
he does it you know in a light-hearted
way if that's possible is that possible
I don't know it's possible but he seems
to pull it off I mean you can even see
just just what I just read you know you
can see he's having a conversation with
you about it mm-hmm you know he's having
a conversation so that's what it's like
let's go back to the book and I'm gonna
pick up in a section where he's kind of
explaining and and I talked about this
with Jordan and by the way yeah so if
you haven't listened to 155 with Jordan
Peterson where we we discussed some of
this some of the ideas in this book we
don't we don't delve into the book too
much and I'm actually gonna cover those
parts there's two little sections that
we covered I'm gonna cover them again
today and kind of go in a little bit
more but if you haven't listened to 155
listened to 155 and then then come back
and listen to this this one this section
of the book
Solzhenitsyn is talking about the fact
that he's a war hero for all practical
purposes and he's about to get rolled up
and arrested by his brigade commander
and here he's talking about his brigade
commander in the situation that he's now
going into ten days before I had led my
own reconnaissance battery almost intact
out of the fire pocket in which the
twelve heavy guns of his artillery
valiant battalion
had been left and now he had to renounce
me because of a piece of paper with a
seal on it I knew instantly I had been
arrested because of my correspondence
with a school friend and understood from
what direction to expect danger so he's
been a fire pocket if you don't know
what that means it means he was
surrounded by the enemy and he was able
to lead his troops out of there almost
intact which means they took some
casualties maybe lost some guys but he
was able to lead his men out of there
and yet he wrote a letter and he
mentions earlier like what he says in
the letter basically says that the
leadership the Stalin's making some
mistakes and guess what they scream
those letters they read what he wrote
and they arrest him so war is hell and
he talks a little bit about that here
for three weeks the war had been going
on inside Germany and all of us knew
very well that if the girls were German
they could be raped and then shot this
was almost a combat distinction had they
been Polish girls or our own displaced
Russian girls they could have been
chased naked around the garden and
slapped on the behind an amusement no
more by the way that's just a little a
little shot of what that war between the
Russians and the Germans was the
Russians in the German we talked about
in Stalingrad but and we talked a little
bit about what happened with civilians
there's a little taste of what happens
to civilians in those situations it's a
nightmare going on the history this is
chapter 2 the history of our sewage
disposal system and this is where he
expands and explains sort of his view of
the prisons as a whole
back to the book it is well known that
any organ withers away if it is not used
therefore if we know that the Soviet
security organ or organs and they
christened themselves with
this vile word praised and exalted above
all living things have not died off even
to the extent of one single tentacle but
instead have grown new ones and
strengthened their muscles it is easy to
deduce that they have had constant
exercise through the sewer pipes the
flow pulsed sometimes the pressure was
higher than X then had been projected
sometimes lower but the prison sewers
were never empty the blood the sweat and
the urine into which we were pulped
pulsed through them continuously and he
uses this this term which I guess the
the Soviets actually called the prison
system organs and how the blood of the
organs was these people and this is
something that I talked a little bit
about with Jordan back to the book and
even though Lenin at the end of 1917 in
order to establish strictly
revolutionary order demanded merciless
suppression of attempts at Anarchy on
the part of drunkards hooligans
counter-revolutionaries and other
persons so that's how it starts off it
starts off with that we're going after
these are people that need to be rounded
up the people that need to be rounded up
are drunkards hooligans counter
revolutionaries in other persons that's
where it starts and then it continues
and it goes on and he writes an essay
Lenin writes an essay called how to
organize how to organize the competition
and he proclaimed this again this is Len
pro crank proclaimed common you the
common United purpose of purging the
Russian land of all kinds of harmful
insects and the term insects and under
the term insects he included not only
all class enemies but also workers
malingering at their work for example
the typesetters of the Petrograd party
printing shops so you can see you can
see this is starting to expand already
it starts off just hey it's hooligans
and drunkards and counter
revolutionaries now all of a sudden it's
getting towards
workers that are being lazy you're being
a little bit lazy guess what you need to
be you need to be arrested and you're
one of these insects and then this is
how this grows and he goes through this
massive list of the people that need to
that become insects and he describes him
as insects so this included local self
governing bodies in the provinces they
were insects and people in the
co-operative movements they were insects
as were anyone that owned their own home
was an insect there were not a few
insects among the teachers in the
gymnasiums and the church parish
councils were made up almost exclusively
of insects all priests were insects and
all those Tolstoi ins who when they
undertook to serve the Soviet government
for example on the railroads refused to
sign the required oath to defend the
Soviet government with gun in hand
thereby showed themselves to be insects
to the railroads were particularly
important for there were indeed many
insects hidden beneath the railroad and
telegraphers they were insects and he
just goes on and on um
all Russian Executive Committee of the
Union of railroad workers and other
trade units were also often filled with
insects hostile to the working class
so this paragraph just goes on and on
and basically what if what it ends up as
everyone's an insect that's how it ends
up everyone's an insect and therefore
everyone must be arrested
eventually here's here's another
expansion here the this is the a decree
from the Council of people's come commit
comma czars signed by Lenin on July 22nd
1918 those guilty of selling or buying
up or keeping for sale in the way of
business food products which have been
placed under the monopoly of the
Republic
they deserve imprisonment for a term of
not less than ten years combined with
the most severe forced labor and
confiscation of all their property so if
you operate on any kind of black-market
whatsoever ten years confiscation of
everything you own that's where we're at
right now
1921 began with the Cheka order number
ten dated January 8th to intensify the
repression of the bourgeoisie now when
the Civil War had ended repression was
not to be reduced but intensified so the
civil war is over the revolutions over
and you think okay the revolution is
over we can back off a little bit no no
now we're gonna go harder in that same
year the practice of arresting students
began the arrests of members of all non
Bolshevik parties were expanded and
systematized not one citizen of the
former Russian state who had ever joined
a party other than the Bolshevik Party
could avoid his fate men of religion
were an inevitable part of every annual
catch and their silver locks gleamed in
every cell and in every prisoner
transport on route to the soul that's
the islands and those are prisons monks
and nuns so who's black habits had been
a distinctive feature of old Russian
life were intensively rounded up on
every hand placed under arrest and sent
into exile
as Tonya Kodava CH wrote you can pray
feedly you can pray freely but just so
God alone can hear so you're allowed to
pray but only God can hear it meaning
don't let anyone else hear it and by the
way because she wrote that she got a
10-year sentence for that all persons
convicted of religious activity received
tanner's which is the 10-year sentence
hmm so you can see how this just gets
completely out of control and one thing
about this book is it's it's not really
chronological mmm so it goes through
whole like this first chapters it goes
through from like the revolution all the
way through after the war so and then
you and then in you go through it's not
chronological it just kind of jumps
around a little bit so you have to you
kind of have to just pay attention the
whole time to what timeframe he's
talking about luckily he gives a lot of
dates on when things are happening for
instance here back to the book this
therapy continued full speed from 1927
on and immediately exposed to the
proletariat all the causes of our
economic failures and sorta jizz okay
let's pay attention to this all the
causes of our economic failures and
shortages
so obviously Russia's going through all
kinds of problems at this time and
here's what caused them there was
wrecking and wrecking as their term for
basically a saboteur someone that's
causing the problems is a wrecker there
was wrecking in the people's
commissariat of railroads that was why
it was hard to get aboard the train and
why there were interruptions and
supplies there were there was wrecking
in the Moscow electric power system and
interruptions in power there was
wrecking in the oil industry hence the
shortage of kerosene kerosene there was
wreckage and textile hence nothing for a
working man to wear where the in the
coal industry there was colossal
wrecking hence no heat in the metal of
Giroux in the metal of jury defense
machinery shipbuilding chemical mining
gold and platinum industries in
irrigation and
where there were these pus-filled boils
of wrecking enemies with slide rules
were on all sides so there they have
problems in the country and it's what
the party is saying hey this is because
we've got these these wreckers these
saboteurs everywhere enemies with slide
rules the GPU puffed and panted in its
efforts to grab off and drag off all the
Wreckers in the capitals and in the
Providence provinces the GPU Collegium
x' and the proletarian courts kept hard
at work sifting through the viscous
sewage and every day the workers gasped
to learn and sometimes they didn't learn
from the papers of new vile deeds so you
had the the the the state press putting
out all this is what's happening these
the wreckers every industry every
factory in every handicraft
art l had to find wreckers in its ranks
a noose no sooner had they begun to look
than they found them continues on when
not long afterward the new people's
commissar of the railroads ordered that
average loads should be increased and
even doubled and then tripled and for
this discovery received order of lenin
along with other others of our leaders
the malicious engineers who protested
became known as known as limiters they
raised the outcry that this was too much
and would result in the breakdowns of
the rolling stock and they were rightly
shot for their lack of faith in the
possibilities of socialist transport so
that right there sums up a lot because
you're in this situation and there's
some buddy at the top that's saying oh
we we need to transport more stuff on
the railroads cool just load them up
more any actual engineers are saying
they can't handle that much weight Hey
they can't handle that much weight it's
gonna ruin the trains it's gonna break
the trains and what do they do she
shoot him in the back shoot him in the
back of the head because and they called
him limiters they gave him a name you're
a limiter you just don't want to make
this happen that's your problem
mm-hmm and there's a there's a great
passage that I read in a book that I'm
gonna read right now and this book that
I'm gonna pull a real quick passage from
that's a book called basic economics
written by a famous very famous
economist I should say named Thomas
Salle and he's just talking about he's
talking about how they tried to regulate
prices in the Soviet Union in other
words we're gonna set the prices yeah
everything and he says and it says this
so this is from this is the role of
prices is the name of the chapter in
basic economics by Thomas all the
significant the significance of
free-market prices in the allocation of
resources can be seen more clearly by
looking at situations where prices are
not allowed to perform this function
during the era of the government
directed economy of the Soviet Union for
example prices were not set by supply
and demand but by central planners who
sent resources to their various uses by
direct commands supplemented by prices
that the planners raised or lowered as
they saw fit and now he goes into this
part where he takes these two Soviet
economists and they described a
situation in which their government
raised the price it would pay for mold
skins leading hunters to sell more of
them and here's that description and
this is these two Soviet economists
shmell eV and popoff who described the
situation where the government raised
the price of pay for muskets here we go
state purchases increased and now all
the distribution centers are filled with
these pelts
industry is unable to use them all and
they often rot in warehouses before they
can be processed the Ministry of light
industry has already requested go scot
common the ministry of light industry
has already requested twice to lower
purchasing prices but the question has
not been decided yet and this is not
surprising its members are too busy to
decide they have no time besides setting
the prices on these pelts they have to
keep track of another 24 million prices
so that's what happens and that's what's
going on you've got somebody trying to
essentially it's the opposite of
decentralized command so you've got
you've got people trying to figure out
what appel to what this moleskin Pelt
should cost and what happens is when
they when the government raises the
price they'll pay for it what do all the
people do they go and gather more of
these pelts and now there's an overstock
of them and they try and get them to
lower the prices so people want to stock
will stop turn them in but they can't do
it quick enough because I got 24 million
other prices that they gotta set for the
government so that in a nutshell is why
all these problems are one of the major
reasons why all these problems are
occurring mm-hmm and whenever somebody
tries to resist what commands are being
given they're getting shot limiters yeah
and this is one I talked about a little
bit with Jordan in September 1930 the
famine organizers were tried with a
great hue and cry they were the ones
there they are there were 48 wreckers in
the food industry
Stalin carried out the first such effort
in connection with the trial of the
famine organisers and how could it not
succeed when everyone was starving in
mountainous Russia and everyone was
always looking about and asking where
did all our dear bread get to therefore
before the court verdict the workers and
employees wrathful II voted for the
death penalty for the scoundrels on
trial
it was the newspaper
of millions and the roar rose outside
the windows of the courtroom death death
death so for these types of reasons for
this centralized command doesn't work
not to mention we you know what they did
took the farms away from the people that
actually knew had a farm there's
complete famine and their blood they're
blaming it on the 48 people that were
saboteurs inside the the agriculture
industry completely insane and this one
I read with Jordan I'm gonna read it
again in the Russian in Russian a Kulak
is a miserly dishonest rural trader who
grows rich not by his own labor but
through someone else's through usury and
operating as a middleman in every
locality even before the Revolution such
cruel acts could be numbered on one's
fingers and the revolution totally
destroyed their basis of activity
subsequently after 1917 by a transfer of
meaning the name Kulak began to be
applied to all those who in any way
hired workers even if it was only when
they were temporarily short of working
hands in their own families so a Kulak
started off as someone that was trying
to you know rip people off but then they
just started applying it to everyone
anyone that hired someone was a Kulak
and it has a derogatory tone to it
continuing on but the inflation of this
scathing term Kulak proceeded
relentlessly and by 1930 all strong
peasants in general were being or being
so-called
all peasants strong and management
strong and work or even strong merely in
convictions the term Kulik was used to
smash the strength of the peasantry
beyond this in every village there were
people who in one way or another had
personally gotten in the way of the
local activists this was the perfect
time to settle accounts with them of
jealousy envy and insult a new word was
needed for all those victims as
a class and it was born by this time it
had no social or economic content
whatsoever but had a marvelous sound pop
cool actinic a person aiding the cool
acts in other words I consider you a
compliment accomplice of the enemy now
what's interesting about this and I had
I had a bunch of people point this out
this this is when we take words powerful
words and we start to throw them at
people we use them universally that's
that's gonna cause a problem mm-hmm and
you can see it all the time right now in
social media and in the yeah I guess you
see it primarily in social media from
like far left extremists and far-right
extremists to the far right anybody
that's to the left to them is like a
communist to the far left anybody that's
to the right of them is a racist or a
Nazi and they throw those words around
and those words that you shouldn't use
those words it's like using Kulak like
that's not the person that hires someone
isn't a Kulak right like that doesn't
work so we escalate these terms hmm and
that's that's not a healthy thing to do
hmm
I mean I think it was um when yeah I
mean when Jordan Pederson gets compared
to Adolf Hitler yeah right they compared
Jordan Peterson to Adolf Hitler come on
yeah okay you don't like some of Jordans
ideas yeah okay that's cool don't call
them Adolf Hitler yeah like that's just
not realistic yeah it's not helpful to
you know or people don't like his ideas
or whatever like for a specific reason
you know rather than identify the reason
they just like package them up and put a
ugly bowtie on it and be like yeah I I
hate you kind of thing in the right you
know if you think about during
McCarthyism right
it was a anti-american you're
anti-american you're a communist it was
like they were flagging people like that
mm-hmm
so both sides can do this in this case
it's in this case
the it's the Communists be escalating
these terms we've seen the right do it
we see the left do it not a smart thing
to do don't throw those terms out mmm
where they don't belong
yeah talk to him about this a little bit
with Jordan there was a wave and we
talked about wave you talking about
waves of people that would flow into the
prisons and there's all these different
ways she talks about dozens and dozens
of different waves there was a wave four
snipping ears the nighttime snipping of
individual ears of grain in the field a
totally new type of Agriculture activity
a new type of harvesting the wave of
those caught doing this was not small
and included many tens of thousands of
peasants many of them not even adults
but boys girls and small children whose
elders had sent them out at night to
snip because they had no hope of
receiving anything from the collective
farm for their daytime labor labor for
this bitter and not very productive
occupation an extreme of poverty to
which the peasants had not been driven
even in serfdom the courts handed out a
full measure ten years for what ranked
as an especially dangerous theft of
socialist property okay that again
that's why I say this book is kind of
like to read right I mean he's he's he's
kind of funny right an especially
dangerous theft of socialist properties
talking about taking one ear of of grain
yeah is he saying that like on his own
kind of thing or is is that what what
the people would say that's the same as
Co that's what the authorities you stole
communist socialist property you stole
it
and you must be destroyed yeah in ten
years cuz you took a little piece of
grain yes like these like if you get a I
don't know jaywalking ticket or
something hey you committed a crime here
criminal you know kind of thing ya can
just call someone a criminal yeah
usually has much even though technically
you know they're not kind of wrong you
know yeah I got rolled up in Vegas yeah
I got rolled up in Vegas criminal I was
with Sarge she
we were crossing one of the big streets
in Vegas and I had to grab something or
I drop something last time I she were
doing something in the walking light
went red but the cars weren't going yet
and Sarge had already walked across so I
just kind of jogged across like you know
before and a car started moving yeah
squad car lights then 10 seconds later
four squad cars I don't know if they
thought I was somebody else so I'm there
you know on on the curb face down face
down Sarge is videoing it yes I was a
criminal way so you but what then did
what they do do you get arrest you know
they gave me a ticket get a walking
freak a walking yeah well I guess
criminal right what's the criminy
probably thought they probably thought
oh we're gonna roll up this drunk idiot
yeah I'm totally there for the UFC you
know I was up there with a fighter I
don't we were probably going to a you
know cut weight or something with a
fighter yeah and there I am getting
rolled up they must have thought I was
somebody else
oh yeah I mean you're on a big you know
and it's like hey this guy looks like he
could trouble or something jaywalking
you know obviously it but the I guess
when you think about a criminal right
criminal what's what's what is that is
that like someone who commits imaginary
in this case what they'd say is oh you
were blocking the transportation of
socialist property there for you that's
a crime against the state you've got ten
years that's exactly what we're talking
about yeah that's exactly what we're
talking about yeah it's like when people
throw around jaywalking get your ten
years for going out and clipping a
single grain of a single year of corn or
grain yeah getting ten years for that
and you know you're 12 years old or
whatever yeah crime against the state
it's like when people throw around the
word treason you know you know like when
people get into political debate no
that's treason
yeah that's yes you're right there's
people throw that word around it
shouldn't be thrown around be careful
when you when you commit treason that's
definitely
it's a big deal man so people say what's
a good example of that's treason
yeah treason is a big deal you shouldn't
throw that word around unless you're
thinking somebody needs to the death
penalty yeah so yes a good example check
back to the book paradoxically enough
every act of the all penetrating
eternally wakeful organs over a span of
many years was based solely on one
article of the hundred and forty
articles of the non general division of
the criminal Criminal Code of 1926 so
this is where all this crap came from
they wrote this Criminal Code of 1926
and the including the great powerful
abundant highly ramified multiform wide
sweeping article 58 which summed up the
world not so much through the exact
terms and of its sections as in their
extended dialectical interpretation in
all truth there is no step thought
action or lack of action under the
heavens which could not be punished by
the heavy hand of article 58 the article
itself could not be worded in such broad
terms but it proved possible to
interpret it this broadly article 58 was
not in that division of the code dealing
with the political crimes and no where
was it categorized as political no it
was included with crimes against Public
Order and organized gangsterism in a
division of crimes against the state
and then he goes through all these
various sections of article 58 which had
fourteen sections in section one we
learned that any action and according to
article six of the Criminal Code any
absence of action directed toward the
weakening of state power was considered
to be counter-revolutionary broadly
interpreted this turned out to include
the refusal of a prisoner in camp to
work when in the state when in a state
of starvation and exhaustion that was a
weakening of state power and it was
punished by execution because if you're
in prison and you're starving but you're
not doing the work you're supposed to do
you're doing something that's hurting
States they need to die this is okay you
can't I was having trouble and I think
even Jordan like we were trying to get
the explain that this is like a sick
comedy yeah like you can't we kept
saying back and forth to each other
we're like you can't make this up you
can't make this up like you can't make
that up
mmm and this is real yeah this a sick
comedy that's an interesting yet kind of
accurate way you know it's like you know
how I can't think of an example you know
someone will like he'll say I don't know
cable actually you know what it was it's
like some cable commercial they say they
do this it's in a funny way a comedy way
they'll say hey um don't get cable
because if and then they'll say like
what does he say so something like yeah
if you don't listen to your parents you
don't do your homework if you don't do
your homework you don't get a good job
if you don't get a good job you don't
you know and it's this whole thing you
had the in rack house yeah so don't end
up in a crack house you know kind of
thing and they relate it to the singing
it's like I see what you did there you
know in each one but it's like you just
mean funny like obviously that's not
that you know but they're just drawing
all these parallels to everything so
this lonely must be the same you know
kind of thing you know like yeah if you
get kid if you cancel keep oh I forget
hug those but well to your point this is
that kind of this sounds like yes be
that crazy exactly but there but this is
real when our soldiers were sentenced to
only 10 years for allowing themselves to
be taken prisoner action injurious to
the Soviet military might this was
humanitarian to the point of being
illegal according to the Stalinist code
they all should have been shot upon
their return home so they're saying you
know what the people that were allowed
the Soviet soldiers that allowed
themselves to be captured they only got
10 years which is actually kind of
illegal because they should have been
shot via article 19 of the criminal code
via intent in other words no treason had
taken place but the interrogator
envisioned an intention to betray and
that was enough to justify a full term
the same as actual so if I just think
you had the intent
that's good enough you're getting 10
years section 3 was assisting in any way
or by any means a foreign state at war
this section made it possible to condemn
any citizen who had been in occupied
territory whether he had nailed on the
peel of a German soldier shoe or sold
him a bunch of radishes you get your
tenner right there there's these two
things
psh which is suspicion of espionage and
then nsh which is on proven espen
espionage you can charge someone with
unproven espionage what does that even
mean hey we're just you know we're
you're guilty for unproven that's like
you're guilty of unproven murder what
does that mean well it's not proven but
that's what you're guilty of and that's
why you're gonna die yeah or maybe it's
the kind like you know here you they'll
say like hey he's uh he's an alleged you
know before you're proven in the court
of law kind maybe you're in that window
you know no even espionage and you're
gonna go to prison for 10 years for it
section 8 covered terror terror was
construed in a very broad sense not
simply a matter of putting bombs under
governor's carriages but for example
smashing the face of a personal enemy if
he was an activist in the party or the
police that was terror and then he
starts talking about section 10 which is
propaganda or agitation containing an
appeal for the overflow subverting or
weakening of the Soviet power and
equally the dissemination or preparation
or possession of literary materials of
similar content so any if you're drawn
in propaganda you can get trouble but
here we go
the term preparation of literary
materials covered every letter note or
private diary even when only the
original document existed so anything
that you write down is subject well
that's why he went to prison for a
letter the real law underlying the
arrest all those years was the
assignment of quotas the norm set the
planned allocations every city every
district every military unit was
assigned a specific quota
arrests to be carried out by a
stipulated time that's like when cops
get the the quota for the speeding
tickets
yeah that's when you get the ticket
refer for the 38 in a 35
is that true though sometimes it is yeah
I don't know I thought I mean I thought
it's true but I have no idea like is
that just a myth
you know how like people they did
they're just mad because they got a
ticket it's not even real you know like
that's not even a real thing mmm I have
no idea it could be a method I just
believe yeah you know cuz you've
probably got that ticket when you're
going 38 in the 35 me neither that's why
I'm questioning it I did get pulled over
a few months ago but lie bruh you tinted
windows no I was going too fast in this
area
Oh straight-up speeding yeah but you got
off B give you a break yeah cuz they
recognize you no check back to the book
piles of victims hills of victims here's
some other people get arrested an
electrician had a high-tension line
break in his sector 58 seven that's the
article 20 years a plumber turned off
the loudspeaker in his room every time
the endless letters to Stalin were being
read his next-door neighbour denounced
him we're aware is that neighbor today
he got SOE
socially dangerous element eight years
by the end of number by the end of
summer 1941 becoming bigger in the
autumn the wave of the encircled was
surging and again the waves talking
about waves of prisoners that are
showing up the waves of the encircled
were surging in these were the defenders
of their native land the very same
warriors whom the cities had seen sent
off to the front with bouquets and bans
a few months before who had then
sustained the heaviest tank assaults of
the Germans and in the general chaos
then through no fault of their own had
spent a certain time as isolated units
not in enemy imprisonment not at all
but in temporary encirclement and later
had broken out you understand what that
means that means they're surrounded by
the enemy didn't get captured by the
enemy they get surrounded for a little
while and then they break out and they
get back to friendly lines and instead
of back to look and instead of being
given a brotherly embrace on their
return such as every other army in the
world would have given them instead of
being given a chance to rest up to visit
their families and then return to their
units they were held on suspicion
disarmed deprived of Rights and taken
away in groups to identification points
and screening centres where officers of
the special branches started
interrogating them distrusting not only
their every word but their very identity
traitors of the motherland under 58:1 be
but at first until the standard penalty
was finally determined they got less
than 10 years you can't imagine that
people would go along we can't imagine
that people go along with this right the
level of fear that you have to have as a
nation and as a people to go along with
that right there are our frontline
troops were surrounded by the enemy they
managed to escape and get back and now
we're gonna put them on trial and put
them in prison
it's it's it's insanity next chapter
talks about interrogation going to the
book if the intellectuals in the plays
of Chekhov who spent all their time
guessing what would happen in 20 30 or
40 years had been told that in 40 years
interrogation by torture would be
practiced in Russia that prisoners would
have their skulls squeezed with iron
rings that a human being would be
lowered into an acid bath that they
would be trussed up naked to be bitten
by ants and bedbugs that a ramrod heated
over a Primus stove would be thrust up
their anal canal the secret brand that a
man's genitals would be slowly crushed
beneath the toe of a jack boot and that
in the luckiest possible circumstances
prisoners would be tortured by being
kept from sleeping for a week by thirst
and by being beaten to a bloody pulp
not one of Chekhov's plays would have
gotten to its end because all the heroes
would have gone off to insane asylums if
the intellectuals in the plays of
Chekhov who spent all their time
guessing what would happen in 20 30 or
40 years had been told that in 40 years
interrogation by torture would be
practiced in Russia that prisoners would
have their skulls squeezed within iron
rings that a human being would be
lowered into an acid bath that they
would be trussed up naked to be bitten
by ants and bedbugs that a ramrod heated
over a Primus stove would be thrust up
their anal canal that a man's genitals
would be slowly crushed beneath the toe
of a jack boot and that in the luckiest
possible circumstances prisoners would
be tortured by being kept from sleeping
for a week by thirst and by being beaten
into a bloody pulp not one of check-offs
plays would have gotten to its end
because all the heroes would have gone
off to insane asylums
horrible so they had these you know
they're doing these savage
interrogations and torture continuing on
the time allotted for investigation was
not used to unravel the crime in 95
cases out of a hundred to exhaust we're
down
weaken and render helpless the defendant
so that he would want to end it at any
cost
then he talks about some of the methods
that were used and you talked about some
of the torture and these were just some
of the kind of the the basic the the
baseline abuse that you're gonna get
you're gonna get kept from sleep you're
gonna get persuasion they'd say look
you're gonna get prison term no matter
what happens but if you resist you'll
croak right here in prison you'll lose
your health but if you go to camp you'll
have fresh air and sunlight so why not
sign this paper right now they do that
they do they do psychological contrast
you know good cop bad cop humiliation
extreme confusion intimidation they tell
them we've got hard labor camps now if
you confess you go to an easy camp but
if you're Stunner stubborn you'll get 25
years in handcuffs in the mines they lie
of course they play on the affections
for those one loved will arrest your
daughter and locker in a cell with
syphilitic s--
that's that one that they always throw
right they're gonna break they can't
break you cool hmm guess what they're
gonna do to your daughter guess what
they're gonna do to your wife guess what
they're gonna do to your son mm-hmm now
he has a great paragraph and I talked
about this a little bit with Jordan but
it's a reflecting on his behavior and
this is when he started talking and
again I skipped through a lot of the
interrogation you have to read the book
you have to read the whole book and if
you really jump into that I hit the the
high wave tops of it and this section
he's talking about the guards right the
people that they call he called them
blue caps these are people that were the
guards the people that were processing
you through the gulags and you know much
like most like Jordan kind of talks
about seeing himself as the bad guy
right the perpetrator as opposed to
always seeing like oh everyone thinks I
wouldn't do that I'd be one of these
victims he saw Smithson sees himself in
a way he reflects on the way he behaved
actually as an officer as a privileged
officer in the Russian army
and this is this is such a great little
section about leadership because it
tells you what not to do as a leader so
here we go and this is a great start off
to this it starts off here back to the
book Pride grows in the human heart like
lard on a pig I tossed out orders to my
subordinates that I would not allow them
to question convinced that no orders
could be wiser
let's check number one right there is
these are things not to do as leader I
throw out orders to my subordinates
without letting him question them
convinced in his own mind that dije my
orders are the best worst completely
wrong
next even at the front where one might
have thought death made equals of us all
my power soon convinced me that I was a
superior human being wrong you're not
better than your troops next seated
there I heard them out as they stood at
attention I interrupted them I issued
commands I addressed fathers and
grandfathers with the familiar
downgrading form of address while they
of course addressed me formally I sent
them out to repair wire under shellfire
so that my superiors would not reproach
me I ate my officers ration of butter
with rolls without giving a thought as
to why I had a right to do it and why
the rank-and-file soldiers did not so
hey we're out there in the field
you're gonna eat whatever shoe leather
and I'm over here eating my butter would
rolls I of course had a personal servant
assigned to me in polite terms and
orderly whom I badgered one way or
another in ordered to look after my
person and prepare my meals separately
from the soldiers I forced my soldiers
to put their backs into it and dig me a
special dugout at every new bivouac and
to haul the heaviest beams to support it
so that I would be as comfortable and as
safe as possible and wait a minute yes
my battery always had a guardhouse -
meaning a little prison cell
what kind of guardhouse could there be
in the woods it was a pit of course
although it had a roof on it it talks
about imprisoning some fish cough was in
prison there for losing his horse and
popped off from maltreating his carbine
yes just a moment I can remember more
they showed me a map case out of a
German hide not human but from a car
seat but I didn't have a strap for it
and I was unhappy about that then all of
a sudden they saw some partisan
commissar from the local district party
committee wearing just the right kind of
strap and they took it away from him we
are the army we have seniority
finally I coveted that scarlet box and I
remember how they took it away and got
it for me
that's what shoulder boards do to a
human being so when you get rank when
you put on those shoulder boards mm-hmm
keep your ego in check don't don't act
like that
then believe me I mean I saw plenty of
people like act like that in the
military and they were hated by their
troops hmm continuing on so let the
reader who expects this book to be a
political expose slam its cover shut
right now if it were only also simple if
only there were evil people somewhere
insidiously committing evil deeds and it
were necessary only to separate them
from the rest of us and destroy them but
the line dividing good and evil cuts
through the heart of every human being
and who is willing to destroy a piece of
his own heart so if you're not careful
you got that evil in you during the life
of any heart this line keeps changing
place sometimes it's squeezed one way by
exuberant evil and sometimes it's shifts
to allow enough space for good to
flourish one and the same human being is
at various ages and under various
circumstances a totally different human
being at times he is close to being a
devil at times to sainthood but his name
doesn't change and to that name we
ascribe the whole lot good and evil
and that's a line that you here Jordan
Peterson read that line a lot or say
that line a lot a line dividing good and
evil cuts through the heart of every
human being so we've all got a little
piece of darkness in our hearts that you
need to watch out for continuing on a
little bit on that theme the trouble
lies in the way these classic evildoers
are pictured they recognize themselves
as evildoers and they know their souls
are black and they reason I cannot leave
unless I do evil so I'll set my father
against my brother I'll drink the
victims sufferings until I'm drunk with
them but no that's not the way it is to
do evil a human being must first of all
believe that what he is doing is good or
else that it's a well-considered act in
conformity with natural law fortunately
is in the nature of the human being to
speak to seek a justification for his
actions ideology ideology that is what
gives evil doing it's long sought
justification and gives the evildoer the
necessary steadfastness and
determination that is the social theory
which helps to make his acts seem good
instead of bad in his own eyes and
other's eyes so that he won't hear
approaches and Kurt curses but will
receive praise and honors that was how
agents of the Inquisition fortified
their wills by invoking Christianity the
conquerors of foreign lands by extolling
the grandeur of the motherland the
colonizers by civilization the Nazis by
race the jacobins
early and late by equality Brotherhood
and the happiness of future generations
thanks to ideology the 20th century was
faded to experience evildoing on a scale
calculated in the millions this cannot
be denied nor passed over nor suppressed
how then do we dare insist that
evildoers do not exist and who was it
that destroyed these millions without
evildoers there would have been
no Archipelago so this is again
something that we see a lot today when
people get on and we see in the past
obviously gave all the examples right
there I mean the Inquisition we haven't
covered that on the podcast yet but we
probably need to because that was a damn
nightmare yeah and it was a nightmare
with people that were saying hey this is
for the good of Christianity yeah and
you can go right on down the list when
people make do when people do evil they
have this ideological
oftentimes have this ideological backing
behind they're doing it for this great
cause and he gets here and and we I got
a book in the in the queue that's
probably gonna get done which we're
gonna approach this thing right here
evidently evildoing also has a threshold
magnitude yes a human being hesitates
and Bob's back and forth between good
and evil all his life he slips falls
back clambers up repents things begin to
darken again but just so long as the
threshold of evildoing is not crossed
the possibility of returning remains and
he himself is still within reach of our
hope
but when through the density of evil
actions the result either of their own
extreme degree of absoluteness of his
power he suddenly crosses that threshold
he has left humanity behind and without
perhaps the possibility of return so
there's some situations where people
just go they're not coming back they're
just gonna do evil mm-hmm that's the way
it's gonna be
and I have a book in the queue right now
that we're probably gonna do that will
explore that departure from being able
to return continuing on the only soldier
in the world who cannot surrender is the
soldier of the world's one and only Red
Army that's what it says in our military
statutes you cannot surrender no
surrender there is war there is death
but there is no surrender what a
discovery what it means is go and die we
will go on living and if you lose your
legs yet manage to return from captivity
on crutches we will convict you and he
mentions the Leningrad er Ivanov
commander of a machine-gun platoon in
the Finnish war who lost both legs and
was imprisoned incidentally it is very
naive to say what for in other words
what for why they go on a president no
time if government's been moralist they
never imprisoned people and executed
them for having done something they
imprisoned and executed them to keep
them from doing something they
imprisoned all those POWs of course not
for treason to the motherland because it
was absolutely clear even to a fool that
only the Vlasov men could be accused of
treason which is a group that will talk
about them a little bit but there was a
a general name class off that actually
became a leader of Russian soldiers
fighting against Russia alongside the
Nazis so he's saying yeah those guys
were traitors against but the the normal
POWs the normals ones they weren't
traitors back to the book they were
imprisoned all of them to keep them from
telling their fellow villagers about
Europe but the eye doesn't see the heart
doesn't grieve for so just because these
people had seen what it was like mmm you
got to go to prison you know too much
you could have acquired a very harmful
spirit through living freely among
Europeans and if you had not been afraid
escaped and continued to fight it meant
you were a determined person and thus
doubly dangerous in the motherland think
about that because you had the courage
to fight on and escape and get back that
means you're a courageous person and
you're even more of a threat because you
know how they live totally backwards now
like I said this guy flies off he he was
surrounded and wanted to retreat and got
told no and they his army it was
basically a lot most of it was wiped out
and then he was kind of wandering and
escaped somewhat and they joined up
where they were captured joined up with
some other troops that other Russian
troops that were now pissed off right
that they didn't hate you what you eat
you wouldn't allow us to surrender you
wouldn't allow us to break out he one
must allow us to leave so they're pissed
at Stalin and so then they turned and
these flies off guys ended up fighting
and I'm sure we'll do a book on these
guys at some point but you know he
became he became the leader Andrey
Vlasov
and they fought and they fought hard
because they know they knew that they
had no and they they weren't gonna live
if they were captured and in fact
Solzhenitsyn says when we captured them
we shot them and as soon as the first
intelligible Russian word came from
their mouths this just straight up
that's what we're doing oh you speak
Russian cool that means your blast off
man you're done the term vlasova in our
country has the same force as the word
sewage we feel we are during our mouths
merely by pronouncing it and therefore
no endears dares utter a sentence with
voise alight in its subject but that is
no way to write history now a quarter
century later when most of them had
perished in camps and those who have
survived are living out their lives in
the far north i would like to issue a
reminder through these
pages that this was a phenomenon totally
unheard of in Hall the whole history of
the world that several hundred thousand
young men aged twenty to thirty took up
arms against their fatherland as allies
of its most evil enemy right seeing this
never happened hundreds of thousands of
there was hundreds of thousand these
flat soft troops hundreds of thousands
of them how do you get hundreds of
thousands of men who are in the military
like okay we get a traitor we get five
traitors mmm hundreds of thousands and
he says back to the book perhaps there
is something to ponder here who was more
to blame those youths or the gray
fatherland one cannot explain this
treason biologically it had to have had
a social cause because as the old
proverb said well-fed horses don't
rampage then picture yourself a field in
which starved neglected crazed horses
are rampaging back and forth
continuing on there is a simple truth
which one can learn only through
suffering in war not victories are
blessed
but defeats governments need victories
and the people need defeats victory
gives rise to the desire for more
victories but after a defeat it is
freedom that men desire and usually
attain a people needs defeat just as an
individual needs suffering and
misfortune they compel the deepening of
the inner life and generate a spiritual
upsurge that's an interesting concept
that's uh that's what Jill Rogan mm
talking about you need to have some
struggle right you need to have
something to get after and in social
Nets and saying people in a country need
that same thing they need that struggle
hmm they want that struggle and this is
again this is one we spent a little bit
of time on with Jordan and this is when
when one of social Nets ins friends in
the prison Valentin said they were
expecting amnesty they were suspecting
to be set free and here we go back to
because we dried ourselves off Valentin
said to me reassuringly intimately well
all right we are still young we are
going to live a long time yet the main
thing is not to make a misstep now we
are going to a camp and will not say one
word to anything so they won't plaster
new terms of us will work honestly and
keep our mouth shut
and he really believed in his program
that naive little kernel of grain of
caught between towns Stalin's millstones
he really had his hopes set on it and I
was talking about amnesty one wanted to
agree with him to serve out the term
Cosley and then expunged from one's head
what one had lived through but I had
begun to sense a truth inside myself if
in order to live it is necessary not to
live then once it's off then what is it
all for
and of course Jordan and I got in the
big long discussion about playing the
game and yeah I mean I think we both
agreed that there's times where you have
to play the game a little bit yeah and
if you don't well you'll end up in a
worse position so we started talking a
little bit about these kangaroo courts
that went on and here's one of the
judges makes the statement we are not
guided by laws but by a revolutionary
conscience so what does that mean that
means we just make up whatever the hell
we want to make up yeah whenever we're
gonna make up that's what we're gonna do
and in in this book book part one of
volume one he spends a lot of time
talking about these multiple cases he
goes through basically it's like court
dramas and he spells them out pretty
good and there's like the dialogue back
and forth between the accuser and and
the defendants and you know the uproar
from the crowd and it's it's like a lot
it's like multiple court dramas one of
them the Moscow Church trial April 26 to
May 7 1922 there were 17 defendants
including arch priests and laymen
accused of disseminating the patriarchs
Proclamation the charge was more
important than the question of
surrendering or not surrendering Church
valuables and the presiding judge says
do you consider the state's law
obligatory or not and the patriarch says
yes I recognize them to the extent that
they do not contradicts contradict the
rules of PIAT piety comrade back the
presiding judge was astounded which you
know the last analysis is more important
to you the laws of the church or the
point of view of the so
viet government again this is all
spelled out but it ends up May 7th the
sentence was pronounced of the 17
defendants 11 were to be shot another
massive show trial against the engineers
that were again this goes back the idea
that they were considered wreckers and
they had these massive show trials and
here were some of the results of the
show trials where they where they
sentence these guys to massive prison
terms or sentence him to death thus it
was attained with 8 horse traction all
the goals of the trial one all the
shortages in the country including
famine called lack of clothing chaos and
obvious stupidities were all blamed on
the engineer wreckers too
the people were terrified by the threat
of imminent intervention from abroad and
were therefore prepared for new
sacrifices three leftist circles in the
West were warned of the intrigues of
their governments and for the Solidarity
of the engineers was destroyed all the
intelligentsia was given a good scare
and left divided within itself every one
of these show trials well if it wasn't
for the fact that people were being
imprisoned or executed after the show
trials it would be a lot of them they
seemed like kangaroo courts they seemed
comical when you read him next chapter
called the supreme measure which is
about capital punishment capital
punishment has an up and down history in
Russia in the 20 central provinces of
Russia in a period of 16 months from
June 1918 to October 1919 more than
6,000 persons were shot which is to say
more than 1000 per month
the Revolution had hastened to rename
everything so that everything would seem
new thus the death penalty was
rechristened as the supreme measure no
longer a punishment but a means of
social defense so they're executing a
lot of people of course they're calling
it the supreme measure and they refer to
as social defense like we're just a hey
we're just defending ourselves right
back to the book and what kind of
evildoers were these condemned mens
where did so many plotters and
troublemakers come from among them for
example or six collective farmers who
were guilty of the following crime after
they had finished mowing the collective
farm along with their own hands they had
gone back and mowed a second time along
the hum --ax to get a little hay for
their own cows the all-russian
Central Executive Committee refused to
pardon all six of these peasants and
sentence and the sentence of execution
was carried out even if Stalin had
killed no others I believe he deserved
to be drawn and quartered just for the
lies lives of those six peasants so
there you go you already harvested all
the grain you can and then you go out
you do another run to get a little bit
hay for your own cows and they kill you
during those two years of 1937 and 1938
1/2 million political prisoners had been
shot throughout the Soviet Union and
480,000 habitual thieves
in addition so we're talking execution
on just a mass scale that's two years a
million just rattled off I mean a
million back to the book and almost
always a person obediently allows
himself to be killed why is it that the
death penalty has such a hypnotic effect
those pardoned recall hardly anyone in
their cell who offered any resistance
does hope lend strength or doesn't
weaken a man that's a good question
isn't it does hope lend strength or does
it weaken a man you had a talk that I
witnessed recently and you mentioned
this something you just sort of
mentioned for the first time that I
heard where you were talking about Hell
week when you said that they'd say hey
you know you don't get much sleep right
oh yeah
and they say okay now we're gonna give
you guys a break you know six hours
sleep yeah yeah no they'd say something
like hey look your hell week has been
extra hard and we went too hard on you
by accident and the water was colder
than normal yeah so what we're gonna do
is we're going to give you guys we don't
normally do this we're gonna give you
guys an eight hour recovery period so go
go put on warm clothes you know you're
gonna go in the barracks you're not
gonna go in the tents you're gonna go in
your barracks put on put on your dry
clothes and get in your beds and you
guys will wake you up in eight hours
yeah but we need to do a little training
pause right now yeah and then and then
they put you in then they do it and then
they put you in there and you can all
draw and they put you on your bed
in the sound and then 20 minutes later
they come in with machine guns and they
wake you up and say go get the surf
again
and they do and that's one of the things
that gets a lot of people to quit yeah
there's a lot of people to quit right so
that's kind of the point where yeah the
hope can jam you up oh yeah we're that
hope you know like oh I can't believe
and then when it's taken away from you
real quick or something like that oh
yeah well this is a great question
because think if okay if you're in a
situation where you could live or die
right there's times where hey if I'm
gonna die it makes me stronger like hey
I'm gonna go out horror ever yeah
exactly right but also like if I can
hope I can live then that can make you
like a [__] fight a little bit longer
I hope of survival yeah so this hope
lend strength or does it weaken abandon
there's different phases where it does
different things to you yeah
depends on what kind of strength - I
feel like yeah I don't know hope of what
- yeah like life is different life and
death cuz like you know death that's the
end of everything that's like you know
but like yeah but think about this
situation you're this is talking about
death like you're gonna be executed so
let me ask you this so you're gonna be
executed but there's if there's a little
bit of hope that oh maybe the sentence
will get overturned yeah or maybe I'll
get pushed down the road or maybe
they'll do an amnesty and I'll get out
that's hope right yeah so that might
weaken you right because if you're like
look I'm getting executed and I don't
care yeah and you know what when that
guard comes in here it's something some
of my buddies and we're gonna get after
it
oh yeah right so that's gonna make you
stronger so hope might not necessarily
be a good thing I mean you know if you
ever encountered someone that I had no
hope they can be very scary individuals
because they don't care if they live or
die they're not gonna leave I can't lose
yes nothing to lose nothing to lose
you ever see a sports game where it
could go like like a team gets a good
lead and then they just start taking
risks and they start dominating right
yeah I mean it can happen where they get
start getting cocky yeah but like you
can see a sports game where easy it
happens in fights
it happens in MMA fights the I start
getting the upper hand
in jiu-jitsu I started getting the upper
hand I take a little bit more risk but
the risk as long as the risk payoff that
Nelson and your if you and I are oh and
I take a little risk
I grab for the takedown yeah right I'm
feeling cocky go for the takedown yeah I
get the takedown right now all of a
sudden your your your hope those down
yeah right and mine's going up even more
and more yeah but if you're really tired
and the rounds almost over and you
already lost and now you're just like
well I got no hope I'm just gonna try
for an arm lock you might get it yeah
yeah that's what it's gonna say - it's
like men it's on both sides so it just
depends both really the answer is well
because like look MMA analogy good one
my opinion to wear let's say I'm down as
a football team as a whatever you start
throwing Hail Marys doing that kind of
stuff you know it's like you have kind
of less hope we're gonna lose anyway
nothing to lose situation so it does
give you strength in that way but at the
same time if you're way ahead yeah I can
pick my risk I'll put my second string
guys in there give them some reps
whatever cuz if you know if the wrist
does it pay off or whatever we're still
ahead so we're you know man I don't know
yeah it just depends you know what you
do I think the thing is here you got to
pay attention as a human to what the
hope is doing to you right yeah this is
a good lesson learned - what is the hope
dude because it happens in your life -
right like maybe you're like at a job
and you're like well I might get that
promotion so I'm just gonna stick it out
yeah stick it out a little bit longer oh
yeah and then but whereas if you're like
hey you're not getting promoted you back
alright you know I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna get my resume together I'm gonna
get my act together and I'll put that
work if you have hope it makes you a
little weaker yeah yeah so you got to
pay attention to it but it could make
you stronger though you'd be like oh I
might get the promotion so I'm gonna so
I'm gonna work hard right saying yeah
you got paid attention was doing to you
that's what you got to do hope isn't
always good it's not bad it's not good
yeah you're all you got to monitor your
hope don't get your hopes up
yeah monitor you hope there you go that
continues on here we go
if the condemned men in every cell had
ganged up on the executioner's as they
came in and choked them
wouldn't this have ended executioner's
sooner than the appeals to the
all-russian Central Executive Committee
when one is already on the edge of the
grave why not resist but wasn't
everything for doomed anyway from the
moment of arrest yet all the arrested
crawled along the path of Hope on their
knees as if their legs had been
amputated monitor your hope he describes
sort of death row in one of the prisons
there were four death cells in this
prison in the same corridor as the
juvenile cells and the hospital cells
the death cells had two doors the
customary wooden door with a peephole
and door made of iron grading each door
had two locks and one jailer had the
block supervisor each had a key one
jailer and if the block supervisor each
had a key to a different one so the
doors could only be opened by the two
together cell 43 was on the other side
of a wall of the interrogators office
and at night while the condemned men
were waiting to be executed their ears
were tormented by the screams of
prisoners being tortured
talks about the idea of hunger strikes
which they did some hunger strikes along
the way from our experience in the past
and our literature of the past we have
derived a naive faith in the power of a
hunger strike but the hunger strike is
purely a moral weapon it presupposes
that the jailor has not entirely lost
his conscience or that the jailer is
afraid of public opinion only in such
circumstances can it be effective so
yeah the Soviet prison didn't care yeah
say whatever you want
we control the press yeah oh and by the
way you think I'm gonna feel guilty that
you're starving no I'm not ever oh and
by the way if I do feel like I want to
make you live guess what they did forced
artificial feeding this method was
adapted without any question from the
experience with wild animals in
captivity artificial feeding has much in
common with rape and that's what it
really is for big men hurl themselves on
one weak being and deprive 'it of its
one interdiction they only need to do it
once and what happens to it next is not
important the element of rape in here's
in the violation of the victims of will
it's not going to be the way you want it
but the bit but the way I want it lie
down and submit they pry open the mouth
with a flat disk then broaden the crack
between the jaw and insert a tube
swallow it and if you don't swallow it
they shove it down farther anyway and
then pour liquefied food right down the
esophagus and then they massage the
stomach to prevent the prisoner from
resorting to vomiting the sensation is
one of being morally
defiled
and this is it's the it's a closing of
this part of the book we no longer know
the answer to the question is the soul
of a person in the new type prison in
the special-purpose prison purified or
does it perish once and for all if the
first thing you see each and every
morning is the eyes of your cellmate who
is gone insane how then shall you save
yourself during the coming day and like
I said that's I'll take that as a spot
to close out that part one of this book
about the gulag and I think that is a
question
that we can ask ourselves a lot in our
current world but how can we save
ourselves every day when you look around
at the world when it looks sometimes
like the world is going insane when
people are going crazy you have to kind
of work to save yourself every day you
have to pull yourself back into sanity
and back onto the path and not allow
yourself to become a prisoner of your
own personal gulag and these gulags
these Soviet gulags if you want to build
your own personal gulag in your life you
do it the same way that the Soviets did
it you do it with lies lies on top of
lies
when the Soviets lied on top of lies to
build these gulags and in your life if
you lie to yourself if you allow that to
happen and you put lies on top of lies
you will build yourself your own
personal gulag so don't allow it don't
lie to yourself and instead keep
yourself out of that prison and keep
yourself free by telling yourself the
truth
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight and I know echo you've got some
ways that we can kind of help keep
ourselves free by staying on the path
sure on top of telling the truth
on top of telling the truth which is
yeah kind of the key right the key
element it's a key element for sure I'm
still kind of tripping on the hope thing
you know if that gives you strength or
or takes it from you right that's how
you put it or that's how we put it right
it takes it from you I was I was talking
to Dakota yeah the other night and we
were talking about after the big event
you know where he lost his team and all
that and we just talked a little bit
more detail about if you remember in the
book a few days later he goes on another
operation that's just as crazy hmm or
maybe not just as crazy but it's like
it's really bad yeah and he was doing
some definitely some some crazy things
and putting what's the military term
that we say he was going above and
beyond the call of duty and putting
himself at great risk hmm and I said to
him you know we're kind of like lap you
know the code is so good to go and so
awesome and we were just like laughing
and I was like bro you didn't I mean at
that point I'm like you just you know
you lost your whole team I go you didn't
care if you lived or died he goes not
even not at all yeah and so in that
situation like he had no hope at that
moment in time right and guess what he
did whatever he had to do yeah he's like
oh I got to go save the I gotta go run
across the open field where there's
machine-gun fire come cool I'll go oh
wait I knew dude again I'll go again all
I need to do it again I'll go again yeah
cuz he didn't have hope and in fact that
he didn't have hope gave him strength
at that moment yeah you know at that
moment but if you talk to him now it's
reversed he's got his kids got his
little daughters you know what I mean
he's got like hope for the future yeah
and that's what makes me strong right
now so it keeps him strong yeah so I
mean what's the formula right I mean
it's the formula is monitor your home is
it any depends on who you are right
because they consider yourself let's say
all hope is lost you know I got a you
know go across do all these crazy things
above and beyond I could be if I have a
different attitude I could be like why
like why fight it kind of thing let
death impending doom you know just kind
of take its course kind of thing right I
mean could yeah that could be regard for
his own safety that's the that's the
phrase I was looking for yeah it's a
complete disregard for his own safety
yeah but that's like a specific like
approach you know that's it like a
different attitude you know like some
people they'll be like oh I'm gonna you
know like I'm I'm doomed anyway so I
fight it and then yeah right like I'm
doing so so I'm gonna just search screen
for the points and check this out
you can also be like I hope I can make
it out of here so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna hide right here and do
anything yeah right so that's the same
dislike the reverse is the reverse so
it's like and then if if you're in a bad
situation and you're like well I hope I
can make it I've got hope that I can
live through this situation so I'm just
gonna get down I'm just gonna hide gonna
get behind this little you know rock
outcropping and hope this goes away
right hope they don't see me
oh you don't hope hope hope yeah and
that's the example of the whole I guess
what happens when you do that the enemy
maneuvers on you and you get killed
whereas if you go like you know what I'm
going out I have no hope I'm gonna
attack but by the way the enemy who's
hoping they can take you and hoping that
you're gonna stay there when you when
you do something that they didn't hope
for that's gonna smack them in the face
yeah but like if but then on the reverse
side of that right so you have a
different attitude even though you have
hope right if all is lost do you think
but I have this little shred of hope so
I'm just gonna go throw a Hail Mary
yeah that's hope yeah
rather than just like cowering in the
corner and dying or whatever but you
wouldn't be throwing a Hail Mary unless
that was the only way like that was
their only hope shred it was your only
don't say like if you that's what I'm
saying like if you have two different
approaches you know monitor your hope at
the end of the day that's how you got a
monitor your home I got to make sure
that what cuz there's you got to be
careful too
because sometimes you know if you have
no hope right if you out well I have no
hope so I'm just good do that right
let's say you're in a bad situation a
combat situation hey I got no hope so
I'm just gonna lay here and like I guess
that's right you were saying yeah oh
yeah I got no hope so I was gonna lay
here yeah instead of hey I got no hope
so I'm just gonna go out in a blaze of
glory let's get psyched yeah yeah yeah
so if you monitor it you go wait a
second I have no hope okay I'm gonna at
least go out hard I'm gonna go get some
at a minimum right gonna take some
people with me bad guys yeah save some
of my good guys if I can do that
yeah that's good as opposed to have no
hope we're doomed
yeah monitor your home remember that
remember of Shawshank Redemption yes I
have seen that movie said that where he
was like hey they got red Morgan Freeman
he's saying hey don't be careful with
that whole thing it'll drive you insane
or something like that like if you hope
you'll get out or you hope you're gonna
get pardoned or whatever this situation
was so it's like yeah if you hope you'll
get pardoned and you hold on to that
hope but you get let down it'll create
you know it'll drive you insane and if
you don't have hoping that this do what
he's implying if you don't have hope he
just said basically accept your
imprisonment so you can focus on or
concentrate on living prison life you
know the way it needs to be lived hmm do
the best you can there yeah like don't
have these hope to the outside cuz it'll
make you crazy
that could be decent advice in a
situation like that yeah yeah you say
monitor your hope because right if you
have no hope you could be like well I'm
just gonna just gonna
myself yeah exactly right yeah no you
gotta monitor it in the prison and you
got to make sure that you're not putting
yourself in a personal prison yeah which
are which that to me this idea if you
think about the bad situations in your
life most of them are predicated on you
lying to yourself about something yeah
yeah your everyday ones for sure
yeah right yeah it's weird every time
you like you say something like that
Holly's trying to think of some rebuttal
you know it's weird I feel myself doing
that but yeah no you're right yeah I
think so that you just tell these little
lies yeah lies on top of lies yeah and
in words I what I think what happens
with lies on top of lies is they become
easier and easier to believe oh yeah
like once you believe one of your own
lies then you believe three then you
believe ten then you believe 100 yeah
you know the feeling is the feeling is
you lie to yourself right and or you
could a lot of times lying to yourself
isn't like hey I'm tall when you're not
taught it's not that it's like it's more
of a not admitting certain things that's
more what it is you know like you saw
how you guys say you say look take a
good hard look at yourself in here right
don't and then don't lie to yourself
right so it's usually when you light
yourself in the mirror it's like well I
won't admit that I won't I won't admit
that to myself that I need this or it
yeah should get rid of this or whatever
that's how the light comes you know it's
lie by omission I think yeah the more
you do it yeah but then you and then you
live to see another day oh it's a
miracle so it must kind to be true it
must not be that big of a deal my
whatever you know my doughnuts that I
eat every morning for breakfast must not
be I'm still here those wise yeah so
it's so no one's bringing it up no one's
bringing it up to me kind of things so
it's like it's not really it's not like
pulling at me that much so it gets
easier and easier to kind of it's almost
like sweeping it under the rug kind of
thing you know meanwhile it's festering
in festering oh she got to dock your
cholesterol so high or whatever I'm
saying that subtle Jim you know don't
lie to yourself
you know what else is a prison being on
bottom stuck in your side control in
jujitsu to prison so and here's the
weird thing when you wouldn't he said
that I I did think of this where if I
have and it's I don't even know if I'd
call it hope like if I want to be out
like if I want to escape not that I want
to do the escape or take escape type
actions it's just I don't want to be
there all like it way less like a won't
I won't be able to deal with it as much
as if I say okay I'm here it's like
accepting that I'm longer inside control
you know and I have to take action here
my hope is here not outside there's a
you you have to accept the situation
that you're in
yes can't lie to yourself can't little
prison anyway I think that's what Morgan
Freeman was talking about by the way
nonetheless speaking side control that's
jiu-jitsu
speaking of jiu-jitsu you're gonna need
a key if you're doing jiu-jitsu indeed
yeah we're on the path we're talking
about the path right now right support
yourself in this way by saying in the
path starting jiu-jitsu if you haven't
already a lot of people starting to get
a lot more people yeah sorry jiu-jitsu
zits are getting popular very popular
and for a good reason to I mean shoot so
when you get Agee and rash guard get or
Jinky no question
oh you don't agree with me that's what I
thought anyway good origin main calm
yeah origin main calm its look I guess
so what the look that I was giving you
is sort of the fact that we just
glossing over the fact that these guys
are made a hundred percent in America
yeah would you even on phone back yeah
yeah maybe should talk about well last
time you did you talked about the looms
and all that stuff today you're just
like hey the best case which I guess
that's cool yeah they are they are all
is true for sure 100% yeah and you know
what I'm just about to say this but I
remembered that I do talk about this all
the time on air and off air that it is
cool it kind of like how Pete guys how
they brought back like
the actual making of the ghee for
example yeah like that's a thing now
it's like cool now yeah no one cared
about how your G was stitched and like
no one cared about that stuff
even if they knew the pearl competitions
last time I was Aris I got like legit
explanation of things from Pete Pete and
I were just like it's 10 o'clock at
night we've been working for 8 days
straight and living in words in there
kitten and I'm asking pointed questions
about stuff mm-hmm
about how this thing gets you know what
I mean yes I want to understand it yeah
there's a lot of those guys I had to
learn a lot of stuff bro you can't even
if it's I think it's been five years six
years the amount of information that had
to be learned
yeah from not from no from nothing from
none from trial-and-error funny s Pete
that kind stuff like you can't exhaust
Pete oh yeah you see the twinkle in his
eye yeah he wants to explain it is a
house concerned I was boring you guys
stay off to that for sure but yeah or
Jinky 100% or generous guard 100%
supplements too by the way
you know and I was not I wouldn't call
myself anti supplement not gonna say
that but I wasn't into supplements that
much before now I am because you know
when you come across the one that
actually works that's the thing you know
how the planning people there are plenty
supplements it's they sorta rely maybe
not hundred percent mmm
maybe hundred percent but they rely on
the placebo effect so when you have
supplements like these that actually
work you become a supplement person yeah
so if you want them got joint warfare
for your joints obviously krill oil for
your life like eating your joints join
couldn't your just overall health
discipline when you got to get that
workout and there's discipline drink and
there's discipline go pills go and then
it was mocha you get some kind of mocha
scenario going on
yes technically is warrior kid milk last
night we go to okay there's this light
show Christmas lights show you know the
you know certain neighborhoods they'll
have I guess this one is like super
faint or like shoot tracers it's called
the I think Bilardo I think it's called
Bilardo light show it's like you know
Christmas lights this house they do a
thing it has a whole show people you
know so we go and you know my wife she
likes the Christmas spirit
get on cozy right it's kind of colder
now California cool Iowa no friends main
yeah no offense but California cold will
say you can see your breath that's
something you're talking 49 degrees so
like in in like Michigan or Minnesota
it's 54 below in Montana it's 54 below
zero so anyways a little bit different
sure but still but for the Charles
family a little chilly according to my
wife it warranted maybe a hot chocolate
scenario so look this is what I'm going
to driver it's Pentacles mouse who drive
around we look at all the nice light so
we'll drink our hot chocolate in the car
would bring the kid that'd be fun we can
get out so everyone busting out the hot
chocolate of course what what do you
think my hot chocolate well yeah I know
what that's the warrior kid
Moke hot chocolate I even put some
whipped cream on oh yeah it was nice
actually was surprisingly nice is what I
was this is why usually I drink the
regular milk under different
circumstances this is like boom
milkshake you know but do you get the
kid consider this consider where I was I
had two two kids and one wife always
regular hot chocolate may or may not
have had marshmallows in it either way
regular hot chocolate and me I'm with
okay I'm gonna stick with a protein or a
kiss so you didn't get your kids didn't
have native me that's that's my stuff
here's the thing kids yeah yeah I was
gonna but we're kinda
hurry so and I made the like the game
time laughs it was already made I'm not
gonna be like hey either way actually
that's a good point next time 100%
unless I heat it up tastes the same
yeah literally tasty this is freaking
awesome chocolate so anyways that's
warrior kid mulk you got strawberry and
chocolate and then for I had a guy at
the gym um the other day and he was
using I'm drinking some oak right now
and I was like oh cool I was like
anybody had it enough like one of those
metal water bought like a water bottle
looking thing yeah I go what did you mix
it with needs that water and I go bro
you got to gotta get milk in there yeah
and he goes really and I go yeah I go
almond milk coconut milk what other kind
of milks are there almond milk
I said just get some acid or whole milk
just milk or skim milk whatever I saw
him yesterday he's it bro yeah and I'm
like he was no I'm drinking it all the
time and I know yeah I know and he was
actually telling me he liked it just as
is with water which I can't I can't
I'm not gonna make that claim because I
don't believe it right I'm not saying
like hey if you drink with water it's
gonna be great if you drink with water
it's okay it's like it's like I said
before drink with water it's like a ham
sandwich like it's not if you drink it
with milk it's like prime rib yeah like
a rib eye sure I know what he was doing
I know I know his exact scenario I
wasn't even there I don't even know
you're talking to me he's used to like
drinking protein drink shakes in the
shaker you know after Liv mixed someone
just throw it in with water whatever
that's what you force it down yeah to
open it with it open your mouth with it
yes is gamma tube down your esophagus to
get your protein you don't need to do
that with milk there's no forced feeding
but that's what I'm saying so now he
mixed it same deal same routine but now
we got the milk tastes better cool puts
it in oh yeah you're right okay where's
Jocko let me find them you know kind of
thing and you're like bro you're not
even on the more you are in the milk
train fully but man you could be up here
in first class
cool man either way Jess get on it get
all this stuff or gin man calm also we
have a store we have a storm Jacko's
door dot-com this is where you can get
more rash guards for jujitsu approved by
the way 100% approve this is more you
know representing the path directly win
those rash guards shirts on there it has
beanies ah hoodies legit hoodies and
yeah go to Jocko store calm yep also
chuckle white tea which yes here's a
thing is funny enough my wife is she's
always there chuckle white tea train
this is not but if there was she would
be the engineer until even say I'm about
to get after it right before she yeah I
guess this is why you can't create viral
marketing right you can't be like hey
let's come up with a viral thing for a
jakka whitey hey get on the jock a white
tea train like that doesn't sure yeah
where's mulch a hundred percent and well
the more treats shirt is just formulated
itself that's what I mean yeah it just
it pre-existed in some onion universe
and then when it arrived here it was
like choo-choo get on anyway Chuck wait
T yes deadlift
eight thousand pounds whatever I've been
dead lifting eight thousand pounds for a
long time already so that is less
exciting than it's gonna be for the you
know the people who just start just
saying but yeah sure somebody has a good
deadlift sixteen hundred pounds if you
if you drink two cans oh yeah to say
this but uh no doesn't work that way you
know exactly exactly right nonetheless
in cans and in witty call it dry tea
yeah just prefer the cans personally but
the dredge is good too for sure
available on Amazon and at the chocolate
store right yes sir calm yeah cool okay
everywhere just go online
danke wait tea boom right in your
mailbox also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already on
Google and wherever play wherever you
get pie hey check out the warrior kid
podcast if you got kids or even if you
don't have kids if you know kids get in
the warrior kid podcast I have a couple
more episodes coming out this week of
the warrior kid podcast so you can get
some of that also you can get that
warrior kids so from Irish Oaks ranch
made by an actual warrior kid named
Aiden who makes it with goat milk mmm so
if you want to get some soap so you can
follow his motto which is stay clean and
then YouTube subscribe to youtube if you
want to see what Echo Charles looks like
sure if you want to see what a guest
looks like if you want to see the look
on echos face when I say something that
he doesn't agree with or if you want to
see the look on my face when he says
something that was one of the funniest
outtakes was you talking mhm and then
you'd but you're just showing my face
yeah just like so bored and annoyed and
just there's a few those there's one
where I was talking about justifying
like not doing squats it was really
you're talking about so I'm gonna a lien
thing you know you just shown my face
and I'm just looking at me like like
please get the hint that my face right
now means stop but you were actually
really nice about that I'm generally
nice yeah there's no I'm a pretty nice
person
well sometimes you take advantage of
that with stories that impinge on my
whole situation anyway
psychological warfare which that's what
that is by the way when you're just
looking at me not yawning nothing like
that just looking like it's
psychological or it's psychological
communication anyway the real
psychological warfare is an album with
tracks of Jocko on each track telling
you how to overcome your moments of
weakness that may may creep into your
whole scenario in life when you're on
the path you can get that on itunes
google play and be three platforms or
whatever you know what I said we were
gonna get psychological warfare two out
by Christmas not gonna happen
little delay if you still have some
requests of an area of weakness and you
want us to make a psychological warfare
track so you can crush and destroy that
weakness mm-hmm then just let us know
the you know the usual means yes
yeah online cool yeah all your excuses
there lies by the way that's the working
title also vary up your work though I
was gonna do a video today a workout
video of yourself yep cool and I was
gonna do a kettlebell typical
kettlebells scenario and I was just
gonna start doing curls with it but but
I decided against it because it's kind
of disrespectful it's got a good idea
you should do a workout video where you
just have a barbell kettlebell dumbbell
a sandbag and everything you just
disrespectful anyway my point there
being what it reminded me of of it is
that the crew it was gonna be like
really good like produced video uh-huh
not necessarily with a good camera
nothing like that but just like I'm just
gonna frame it good and it was gonna be
using the on it kettlebell the Cyclops
whatever nonetheless decided against it
because did gonna be kind of
disrespectful because that's not what
kettlebells for obviously but if you do
get kettlebells even if it's funny it's
still disrespectful yeah that's what it
felt like at the time but no you're
probably right yeah at the time I think
yeah all right yes anyway my point is
even though it's a little bit beside the
point
it reminded me of it the point is my new
point is when you want to vary up your
workout curls or otherwise some people
they don't even do curls I used to do
curls you see do curls - don't act like
you don't know I do you go boom get your
stuff from on it calm slash Jocko by the
way kettle bells rings these are things
that not only do I do pretty much every
workout pretty much but this is these
are ones that I strongly recommend to
incorporate rings and this last 15 ton
rings by the way push-ups pull-ups and
the planks whatever those dips yeah I
don't do them as much but the plain
for sure I don't do dips not on the
Rings no why I don't know I just don't
regret he's doing on the bar nonetheless
good job these are those a lot of heat
right there for no dips on the Rings
anyway get them out on it good stuff on
there Barry up the workout incorporate
new things in the workout yeah man it's
good
Mikey and the Dragons is out it is in
stock fully good I'm sorry that it took
a little eight everyone should have
gotten it buyer should get it by
Christmas if you ordered it reasonably
before Christmas you should have it
because we we made it we did it everyone
that ordered it we got an Amazon
fulfilled so appreciate everyone that
ordered it it is now fully in stock we
should not run out again it's Emily if
you have Amazon Prime that's like two
days right yeah yeah I don't know I
don't know when more you're yeah I don't
know when they're cut off time is for
Amazon to get it shipped in time but
yeah those are in the distribution
centers around the country with Amazon
Prime right now so if you haven't gotten
my key in the Dragons for every kid that
you know then you can get it done right
now we got a lot of copies ready to roll
so get it for your kids get it for your
neighbors kids get it for your library
whatever you can also get the way of the
warrior kid books where the worker kid
and marks mission if you want your kids
or kids you know to actually have a good
life this is a great way to start them
off actually having a good life yes
another this is a holiday gift if there
ever one was one discipline equals
freedom feel better I need to post that
video actually I'll post that video
repost all reverence for the book yeah
yeah yeah get that video posted but yeah
because that's a good gift again for
anyone that needs to be first if you
want to get the audio version of that
it's not on audible
it's on iTunes Amazon music google play
etc extreme ownership of course
dichotomy leadership possibly better
than extreme ownership
I've gotten like four last four people I
talked to I was like possibly and
they're like no it's definitely better
and that's kind of weird right yes that
yeah well you go flare up there you know
what I mean maybe but I don't really get
that from what you just said right now I
I here's my hypothesis the people who
are saying that dichotomy leadership is
better than extreme ownership better
than extreme ownership or people who
read extreme ownership and then we're
like yeah you know hell yeah I'm gonna
extreme ownership and then they go in
and they're like okay it's like you know
I made the analogy of the dance major
league right the pitcher he had all this
power but he never control dichotomy
leadership comes in gives him that
control that they wish that they had
yeah they didn't even know they didn't
have it they didn't know they didn't
have it they thought extra medieval
thing a seal buddy of mine came over to
my house the other day and he brought 20
copies of extreme ownership his wife
wanted to give his giving of them to her
team in her company and he goes yeah you
know I'm giving you my wife really wants
give him and she's read it she loves it
and then he goes but she's kind of a
bull in a china shop yes and I was like
okay cool so guess what I did I was like
hey let me give a little song for your
Christmas present and give her a little
Christmas present you know I'm getting a
little something called dichotomy a
leadership because that's the situation
you're talking about you know what
they'll think perfect situation like you
think I'm gonna go take ownership or and
it's like well or even like everyone's
gonna read this book a dichotomy
leadership let's make sure we're
balanced yeah actually though you know
what you know what I just thought of
right now I got it I gotta take it back
maybe maybe not maybe I'm right maybe
I'm not with that whole analogy but you
know what though what's more important
power or about or or or what do you call
accuracy or whatever right because it's
kind of the same thing extreme ownership
is like oh here's what you do full speed
this is what you do and then the
dichotomy is kind of the control element
what's more important control or speed
zoom same controller part yes arguably
control they're both important I think
so - yeah at the end of the day that's
that's the scenario though well you
won't have you won't have anything to
balance if you don't understand the
fundamental principles combat let's
shoot right so yeah that's just the way
it's gotta be
yeah uh yeah so get those books good
Christmas presents I'm the worst gift
giver you're you let me think about if I
get you a gift which is not likely yeah
it'll be great but it's a slim chance
you're getting one how many gifts have
you gotten from me to what I give you
well one actually attempting I don't
think was from you you gave me a copy of
the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual signed like on your own like it
wasn't like hey give me you or like hey
you know hey bruh yes for you go okay it
was cool what else nice it's cool cuz
I've written six books I'm giving you
one 20% you gave my daughter one that's
your talk yes exactly right not me way
different no you gave me something I
think it was like a shirt or something
that I found out like later that day
that it wasn't from you so you get one
gift yeah thanks for that by the way
check also we get a salon front that's
my leadership consultancy and what we do
is go into companies and solve problems
through leadership go to echelon front
comm if you want to work with me and my
team which is life Babb and JP Danelle
Dave Burke Flynn Cochran Mike Sorelli
and Mike bimah also we got the muster
coming up it is live for registration
right now Chicago Denver and Sydney
Australia Kota extreme ownership calm
right now if you want to come they've
all sold out this one has got actually
week we open registration it's already
like these are gonna sell out a lot
faster yeah whatever reason yeah
interesting how your we're going to
Australia yeah look cuz a lot of people
were saying you know you yes for some
reason when I went to Brisbane Australia
yeah and I did a book signing in
Brisbane
dryly and I announce it on like a
Wednesday or a Thursday and that books
any weight on Friday and I showed up and
there was hundreds and hundreds of
people there yeah I was super stoked
about that and it showed that there was
a lot of people that were supporting and
of course we got EF overwatch which is
us connecting proven leaders from spec
ops and combat aviation communities with
companies in the civilian sector that
need experienced leaders to step up and
lead inside their organizations to go to
EF overwatch and fill out the
information there either as a talent
seeker or a career seeker we're waiting
to link you guys up you know speaking of
events mm-hmm
we are doing a live event we are doing a
live event New York City
January 9th details to be announced but
if you want to come it's in a theater
and we're gonna record a podcast live in
the theater and then we're gonna do QA
live I think or maybe I'll send like a
group yeah like the old school let's go
have multiple half-and-half that's what
we're gonna do something like that
anyways calendar yourself
January 9th New York City if you're in
that area or you want to come hang out
come and get some we will see you there
and if you want to link up with us
virtually we are pretty readily
available on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on Facebook
kiba echo is that echo Charles and I am
at Jocko will link and thanks to all the
military personnel out there that are
providing us with this way of life and
you can see how bad life can get when
you read a book like The Gulag
Archipelago also thanks to police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs correctional officers Border Patrol
and all first responders for protecting
this way of life that we have here at
home and to everyone else out there just
remember that this nightmare of the
gulags started when people can't get on
a large scale and on a small scale don't
let that happen
on a large scale and don't let it happen
to you resist that whole opening chapter
about not resisting don't let that
happen
resist resist the weakness resist the
lies resist the things in your life that
will turn you into a prisoner and into a
slave and you do that by going out there
every day and getting after it and until
next time this is echo and Jocko out